certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021.
on that day
i was not only vice president-elect
i was also a united states senator
and i was here at the capitol that
morning
at a classified hearing
with fellow members of the senate
intelligence committee
hours later
the gates of the capitol
were breached
i had left
but my thoughts immediately turned
not only to my colleagues
but to my staff
who had been forced to seek refuge in
our office
converting filing cabinets
into barricades
what the extremists who roamed these
halls targeted
was not only the lives
of elected leaders
what they sought to degrade
and destroy
was not only a building
hallowed as it is
what they were assaulting
were the institutions
the values
the ideals
that generations of americans
have marched
picketed
and shed blood
to establish
and defend
on january 6th
we all saw
what our nation would look like
if the forces who seek
to dismantle our democracy
are successful
the lawlessness
the violence
the chaos
what was at stake then
and now
is the right to have our future decided
the way the constitution
prescribes it
by we
the people
all the people
we cannot let our future be decided
by those bent
on silencing our voices
overturning our votes
and peddling lies and misinformation
by some radical faction
that may be newly resurgent
but whose roots
run old and deep
when i meet with young people they often
ask
about the state of our democracy about
january 6th
and what i tell them
is
january 6
reflects
the dual nature
of democracy
its fragility
and its strength
you see the strength of democracy
is the rule of law
the strength of democracy
is the principle
that everyone should be treated equally
that elections should be free and fair
that corruption
should be given no quarter
the strength of democracy
is that it empowers
the people
and the fragility of democracy is this
that if we are not vigilant
if we do not defend it
democracy simply will not stand
it will falter
and fail
the violent assault that took place here
the very fact
of how close we came to an election
overturned
that
reflects the fragility of democracy
yet
the resolve i saw in our elected leaders
when i returned to the senate chamber
that night
their resolve not to yield
but to certify the election
their loyalty
not to party or person but to the
constitution of the united states
that
reflects its strength
and so of course does the heroism
of the capitol police
the d.c metropolitan police department
the national guard and other law
enforcement officers
who answered the call that day
including those
who later succumbed
to wounds
both visible
and invisible
our thoughts are with all of the
families who have lost a loved one
you know i wonder
how will january 6
come to be remembered in the years ahead
will it be remembered as a moment
that accelerated the unraveling of the
oldest
greatest
democracy in the world
or
a moment
when we
decided to secure and strengthen our
democracy
for generations to
come the american spirit
is being tested
the answer to whether we will meet that
test
resides where it always has resided in
our country
with you
the people
and the work ahead will not be easy
here in this very building
a decision will be made
about whether we uphold the right to
vote
and ensure free and fair elections
let's be clear
we must pass
the voting rights bills that are now
before the senate
and
the american people
must also do something more
we cannot sit on the sidelines
we must unite
in defense
of our democracy
in order
to form a more perfect union
establish justice
ensure
domestic tranquility
provide for the common defense
promote
the general welfare
and secure
the blessings of liberty
to ourselves
and to our prosperity and prosperity
that is the preamble of the constitution
that president biden and i swore an oath
to uphold and defend
and that is the enduring promise
of the united states of america